good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight we spent an awful lot of
time this spring talking about
viruses and how they spread one person
infects another person who infects a
third who then has contact with a larger
group of people and infects 20 more
each of whom and you know how it works
it's exponential
pretty soon individuals thousands of
miles from the source of the outbreak
start getting sick
well we now know that craziness spreads
very much the same way
a single lunatic can pass a debilitating
case of it to millions of
others with just one appearance on msnbc
or a long thread on twitter
hysteria is the most communicable
disease
known to man and we're now living
through a pandemic
of it on memorial day weekend a man
called george floyd died in police
custody in minnesota that's where this
outbreak first began
minneapolis was our wuhan the first
cases appeared a little over a month ago
here's the state of the pandemic now it
was just before midnight thursday when
protesters began dismantling
and toppling the statue honoring
christopher columbus
in civic center park crews moved in
and destroyed what was left one
protester climbing up the statue and
began spray painting its face and hands
possibly symbolizing blood while others
spray painted the words george floyd's
blm for black lives matter and the
communist symbol
[Music]
and they have just torn down the statue
of christopher
columbus the statue has been here since
1931.
so to translate what you just saw into
the clinical language of epidemiology
holy smokes this is getting
really crazy what does christopher
columbus have to do with george floyd
christopher columbus was not a
minneapolis police officer christopher
columbus was
an italian navigator who died more than
500 years ago
columbus probably never even heard of
george floyd he almost certainly didn't
mistreat him personally
so why are people attacking columbus's
statues
well who knows you're definitely not
allowed to ask
questions are not permitted during
hysteria epidemics
logic of any kind seems to dramatically
increase the severity of the symptoms
a patient may appear to be recovering
from hysteria speaking in nearly
complete sentences
bathing independently on occasion but
then a single direct question will send
him into a tail spin
a renewed attack of slogan shouting
anarchist graffiti
hours of hostile tweeting the disease
back and forth
it's safer not to say a word that's
definitely the policy over at the senate
republican conference on capitol hill
republican senators have decided not to
disturb the patients in any way
even as they rampage through america
destroying our culture and history
it's easier to give them what they want
so that's what they're doing
ron johnson of wisconsin and james
langford of oklahoma are both republican
senators
today they introduce legislation to
abolish columbus day
they want to delete it from the national
calendar and replace it with
juneteenth this is a big change
americans have celebrated columbus day
as long as we have had a country since
1792 columbus day is a celebration of
the nation itself that's why it's a
national holiday juneteenth is newer
three weeks ago many people had never
heard of it even the media
seemed oblivious to its existence from
2012 through 2017
cnn did not mention the word juneteenth
a single time on the air barack obama
who was the president
never tweeted about juneteenth once
during the entire span of his presidency
not one time
juneteenth commemorates the freeing of
the american slaves emancipation
is one of the great moments in america's
history it's why we consider abraham
lincoln a hero
but paradoxically and this is odd the
people who are pushing juneteenth on the
country
do not consider abraham lincoln a hero
they're pulling down his statues along
with columbus's
confused well that's the nature of a
hysteria outbreak nothing makes sense
senators johnson langford may be a
little confused as well they describe
themselves as
conservatives improbable as that may
seem
on some level they may suspect that all
the yelling about columbus day and
juneteenth doesn't really have much to
do with
emancipation or civil rights more likely
it's just another way to humiliate and
demoralize americans
on some level they know that but they're
ignoring it it's just easier to do with
the hysteria patients command
unless of course their voters notice
them doing it
a couple of weeks ago senator mike braun
of indiana sponsored a bill designed to
punish the police
at the very moment the country was
undergoing widespread looting arson and
violence rioting
then braun endorsed the radical racial
separatist
blm movement at first bronze republican
constituents didn't seem to realize
their senator had done
any of this but when they found out they
were
enraged and they let him know about it
loudly mike braun is now running away
from his own bill
if mike braun were up for election this
year he would lose
senators langford and johnson are
praying nothing like that will happen to
them
they're hoping to quietly eliminate
columbus day and then move on to the
next item on the riders list of demands
will they be able to do that it all
depends on whether or not you let them
know that you noticed
they're trying to cancel columbus day if
you don't say anything about it
there is no telling what johnson and
langford might do next
just the other day for example the new
york times during a piece suggesting
that we knock down george washington
statues
and purge our country's founder from our
collective memory
today the paper announced that we should
consider closing mount rushmore because
of course racism senators johnson and
langford have not yet endorsed those
ideas at this rate it may not be long
before they do
so the question is what other acts of
revolution and cultural desecration can
we
expect from our suddenly woke republican
senator friends
that's a good question